ce quiz et nous essayons watts
aujourd'hui vous l'aurez deviné vous
l'ambiance un petit peu sombre qui règne
ici on se retrouve sur un jeu d'horreur
et avec le plus strict parce que ça fait
quand même pas mal de temps que la part
utilisé sous le jeu de terrorisme
objectif
l'uci a disparu en 1943 elle aimait
jouer du piano trouver les sept pianos
pour savoir la vérité c'est bien
actuellement d un couloir qui sait que
sa boîte
de là où je suis on dirait un poireau
entre et j'en sais rien ça maintenant
d'accord c'est une à une une allumette
parce que là moi aussi si oui qu'est ce
qui se passe avec tes doigts mon gars
c'est le piano ça te rend un peu tendu
tendue des doigts mais mais mais ne te
mets pas dans cette étape obligée de
faire des bruits en [ __ ] d'accord
c'est le feu à red bull allait le mettre
je sais combien dans tous les sens je
suis pas menti je suis pas d'anti donc
j'ai décidé au bout de 30 secondes de
jeu
quel est donc apparemment il faut pas
trop fâché la femme qui cherche un
dentiste oil et vilaine regarder le
visage le visage de la colère un jeu des
coups de tête contre une roche doit bien
ne m'attaque pas au cul tu as he le feu
de cette [ __ ] lâche l'allumette quoi
je ferai à faire tout ça dans le noir
bonjour mais qui n'a peut-être chercher
son anti dans cette armoire
malheureusement il est personne mais
attendez quand il ya un gros problème de
proportion déjà quelle est la taille de
ces de ces trucs quoi le court ok y'a
pas de poils de proportions je m'excuse
bonjour piano s'il faut que je joue de
petites notes bon ça s'est fait au
pourquoi il ya un bruit c'est toi le
nombre j'ai toujours détesté les ombres
sympa le choix du poster sympa abbas
encore mieux qui dit mieux non non non
non mais non mais non manon et que tu
fais là
l'uci oui tu je suis perdue pour ma part
j'ai un escalier nickel voilà comment se
transformer en statue en une seconde le
plaisir mais c'est quoi ce labyrinthe de
ouf
non ça c'est là d'où je viens encore
plus et tes doigts ficello là tu calmes
direct et tu changeras ta jupe
comment je peux passer là dedans poireau
s'il te plaît de moi je peux pas envoyer
le poireau là-bas au moins me dire un
nantais pas d'accord puis tant pis si
j'ose même pas se montrer un mois ouais
d'accord ça marche
oh oh oh oh dix huit mois excuse moi
excuse moi j'assume excuse moi c'est
juste de l'eau comment ça va mieux ça va
mieux non violente est bien via notte
bien la guitare de la guitare jazz et
d'ailleurs mais plus tu as peur tu me
tues peu fourni le tissu a tapé la vidéo
as tu dois pas te jure je veux pas te
juge t-shirt [ __ ] protègent moins
jeunes rebord hôtesses bourrin et toi tu
aurais pas pu me protéger et non non
mais tu me regardes sur un autre ton un
homo dieu t'a vu un autre poireau
lumineux oh oui mon gars à taez nombre
tu sais que ça là sérieux problème de
silhouettes cette femme
tmc des jambes d'animal pour ta greffer
des jambes de minotaure qu'est ce qu'on
t'a fait du 6au je veux pas savoir météo
blond sa démarche intelligente est
excité a pas besoin d'aller pages jaunes
tsx ylo sexy l'uci laisse pas tranquille
la patte d'oie fils l'on sait c'est que
ça attaque
j'en ai bien peur c'est bien la
puissance du port lumineuse tête avec
moi
il ya plus de notes mais bien une note
quand je suis venu j'ai pas rêver rome -
la note anne hommel m'a protégé en fait
qu'alain qu'alain norpac à dancing
l'accès blague à quoi sert cette porte
sans déconner l'architecte qui a fait ça
est un dangereux psychopathe a envie de
toi
waouh qu'est ce qui se passe ici fait du
bruit pour votre empereur à james à toi
aussi jeune flocons [ __ ] ça nous mène
où ces histoires où il ya plein de
faucon partout j'ai entendu un bruit
your est elle une fille dans un coin
tenez on va à l'autre comme il dit
qu'est ce que c'est c'est un piano un
puits avec une note
il ya un bruit ouais oh [ __ ] traite
des cavernes il y pense jamais à les
aider notre empereur d'accord il y avait
quoi danse puis j'ai envie de savoir
quand même un jour un ya peut-être lui
si on s'est peut-être mais pas celui-ci
au plus il est méga fourbe verde
regarder le à l'arrière le fourbe euh
euh euh euh ok mais peut-être que oui
peut-être
ok pardon excusez moi c'est de l'axé
avec moi on va partir à gauche ça marche
c'est entre toi et moi que tout va jouer
maintenant c'est la famille nos torts
c'est comme ça que tu séduit un homme
dont la newsletter de mine aux femmes
prostituées ça n'a aucun sens quoi ah
mais non mais c'est la salle du du minho
ah non je refuse d'être enfermé est une
créature les cavernes je n'ai toujours
pas de quoi payer on s'en va on note la
longue haleine
[ __ ] j'ai fait l'homme marteau piqueur
ah oui ici à la femme au fond qui va
paraître machin a et pas une autre
ici rien mais c'est le cachot ça et où
les gens s'ennuient pendant des jours
avant de mourir d'une manière affreuse
pourquoi mettrait le seul avec des
livres si elle ne sert à rien pour nous
mettre la pression
jeune page apparaît si tu existes je
t'emmerde
tu es mon seul ami dans ce dangereux je
comprends pas ta langue arrête arrête
sinon lasserai jamais est ok bon lucie
que tu est il arrivé dit lellouche est
parvenu un message un truc parfait mix
par textos tout ce que tu fais là pas de
problème
un as tu n'es pas lucie imposteur a
débloqué opus accueille trois doigts ou
la tête de lézards sur un corps de
lâches dans c'est ça ouais enfin son
feeling juste un feeling of odieux with
you j aimerais savoir qu'est ce qui est
arrivé à lui si on sait qu'il faut
comprendre là à la prostituée minotaure
je viens au p je préfère vous le dire
avant de m'approcher ne vous je veux
juste savoir ce qui est arrivé à l'uci
seriez vous m'indiquer un chemin
quelconque
est ce que ça veut dire oui il faut
tirer la langue peut-être oui les
dangers pas l'agent g pas d'espèces
touquet
ah ah ah non je m'enfuis commun screamer
à la suite à un bon gars c't'un laborde
[Musique]
fin du son orchestre il sera enflammé
mais d'une manière inattendue en voilà
lui si celui-ci mais non mais pourquoi
la cour elle s'enfuit [ __ ] réussi à
trouver les dentistes elle a peur que je
la force à opérer l'autre là qui est
carrément dégueulasse non allez le
retour de leurs quatre fous aux apu
teint j'ai toujours mon micro j'ai
flippé
je commence à en avoir marre de ce jeu
vient jouer chien avec moi j'en ai marre
de la solitude et ou non tué bloqués
dans un puits que tu peux casser en un
coup de tête
est ce que tu te sois un peu humilié à
l'heure actuelle un bon ça souvenirs sur
wikipédia cette vidéo qu'est-il arrivé à
l'uci en 1946 l'uci est morte et ne veux
pas me dire pourquoi bonjour au moins on
a découvert l'existence de poireaux
lumineux de lézards sur un corps à trois
doigts et d'une femme qui cherchait
dangereusement un dentiste
ok alors qu'elle tape une bague en bon
j'étais en train de chercher s'il tient
j'ai pas trouvé mais tant mieux puisque
mais non mais quelqu'un qui joue du
piano il y avait eu un bruit de piano
itou
moi je me barre à bientôt
[Musique]
c
c'est
[Musique]